sur les employés c'est très simple et le
premier ministre vient nous le rappeler
il y aura pas de suppressions d emplois
aidés pour les petites communes rurales
donc c'est effectivement un point sur
lequel on voudrait échanger avec le
premier ministre il a été très rassurant
sur ce point pour ce qui est de la
baisse des dotations il nous a rappelé
également qui aurait pas de baisse des
dotations l'année prochaine mais que au
contraire on allait autonomiser mais
donner plus d'autonomie aux
collectivités leur demander à elle même
dechert les économies mais leur
maintenir les subventions
moi je suis adhérent lr tué d'esprit
constructif dont je suis et l'air
constructif et je suis toujours à jour
de mes cotisations chez bel air
si vous êtes élu vous serez de peut-être
dans le futur vous constructif et l'air
du sénat qui est en train de se demander
si je suis élu je dis est vrai dans le
groupe constructif qui est en cours de
création qui sera en cours de création
qui j'espère sera créé